hey Dave Ramsey Steven Curtis Chapman
here your old pal and man 25 years how's
that possible you must have started when
you were like 12 but congratulations on
25 years of great work inspiring people
helping a lot of folks and proud of you
brother
well thank you my friend well the nicer
humans you will ever meet on the planet
good guy really good guy well in our
25th year anniversary celebration here
on the Dave Ramsey show we're taking a
segment every so often and just
reminiscing our predict producers and
creative team got together and came up
with some subjects first reminisce over
over the time and you know I get we all
kind of got to laughing about what we
used to have to deal with to do a radio
show when we first started of course
technology was a whole whole lot
different than it is right now and so
the stuff we dealt with we actually had
a reel-to-reel tape you ever seen those
great big old reels of tape and that's
how we would do our commercials of
course was with reel-to-reel tape and if
you've never used one of those things
you can stop the tape and then you know
dial it back and listen to it in slow
motion as you're dialing it with your
hands back and hear a certain place so
if you're cutting a commercial and you
mess something up you can dial it back
to there and then cut over the top of
and that was how we would do an edit
worst case we would take a razor blade
and cut the tape and piece it together
repeats it together with other with a
special tape to put it back together and
we were literally editing by cutting
tape with a razor blade to put a
commercial back together and then of
course once we got it solid we would
rerecord it on to these eight-track
looking things called carts for cart
machines and if you ever went into a
music studio in those days there were
racks and racks and racks and racks and
racks I mean hundreds and hundreds of
these carts looked like an 8-track
machine but all it had was one song on
each one
and so the way a DJ in those days they
didn't spin records they would set up
you have two or three cart machines and
you had one with a commercial in it one
with the last song in it and one with a
song coming up and you just had to you
know hit the play and they were staged
so the next one would automatically kick
off as that one as that commercial ended
it would kick the next one off and all
you do just stay ahead of it and keep it
loaded keep the all three cart machines
loaded because it was cycle back through
them are four or five or whatever there
were but and so we would record the
commercials onto those carts then and do
that of course there was not any email
or anything like that in those days we
did have a fax machine
remember those remember that we had one
of those in the studio and so we had a
phone number that you would call in a
call-in number and today of course we
have a call-in number we have Twitter we
have email we have lots of ways you can
contact the show and we'll read your
tweets or your Facebook post or you can
email a Dave on-air at Dave Ramsey comm
right that's how we do it today in those
days though it was just the phone number
or you could call the fax number and fax
in your question but we you would hear
the fax over-the-air you'd hear at the
background we finally figured out how to
turn the ringer off so you didn't hear
it ring but when people started faxing
in you know that you would hear the
other listeners would hear it out there
and then we'd tear it off and read
someone's question that they had faxed
in or their statement that they had
faxed in over-the-air if we wanted to
just like if we want to read your email
or your tweet now we do that kind of
thing and it's how we put the show
together the studio that we were doing
the show in originally was a studio @ WS
m FM 95 which is a country station here
in Nashville and the talk radio station
that we were on at that time wtn was in
housed in that studio and they had not
it was not a real I mean they had the
radio real radio studios for the country
DJ's because that was big time but the
talk we had a studio that the producers
were in the same room with us they
didn't have the
separating us and so when Blake was
taking a call and screening a call
sometimes you could hear him talking
over the air because he was in the same
room with me we did have a piece of
plexiglass they hung from two chains
from the ceiling to try to buffer the
sound but you know and then you just
walk around the end of the plexiglass
and talk we did not have any you know
today if I want to talk to James or to
Kelly or to Zack I'd have to push an
intercom button because they're in a
soundproof room I'm looking at them
through two panes of glass that are
soundproof but uh you know I have to
talk through an intercom if I want to do
that while I'm on the air those days we
just started talking about it finally we
built our own studio in our own building
and we didn't have to drive across town
to do the show and it was basically we
took two closets that were side-by-side
and we put Blake's a little little board
which was like 18 inches by 18 inches a
little tiny production board in there
and a phone system in one side we
knocked a hole in the closet wall
between us and put a piece of Plexiglas
in that so that we had a window to look
through but again it was a soundproof we
could talk through it and so and went
down to staples or office Mac's or
something and found a press board you
know those sawdust tables with the
Formica tops and that kind of thing we
found the one in the corner I think I
paid four dollars for it it was in the
scratching dead corner it brought it
back in that was my table we drilled
holes in that and put the mic stands in
those holes those arms that come up you
know the spring-loaded things to hold
the microphones but you couldn't see it
it was on radio we can care what it
looked like we just cared how it sounded
but it didn't even sound good the
microphones were good we had good
quality mics but the the rooms we were
in were not soundproof and so we ended
up putting up yellow caution tape across
the hallway when we were on the air
because people are in our office would
walk past our show walking down the hall
talking while we were on the air and you
would hear their conversation come over
the air because the door wasn't
soundproof and it was that bad that was
that bad but we pulled it off and 99% of
the time you guys had no idea out there
that you were listening
that was a barnyard and put together
with paper clips and baling wire and
fish hooks and duct tape right I mean
really then we had streaming came to
town we started doing streaming the show
no one did audio streaming and it was a
big problem because all the radio
stations were afraid they were going to
go broke that no one would advertise our
for streaming and of course streaming
live streaming you had to be listening
to the show and most of the people
didn't have enough didn't have enough
Wi-Fi power to do it with wireless so if
you want to hear streaming when it first
came out you're at a hardwired computer
sitting at a desk somewhere we put all
three hours on streaming as soon as it
was available and everybody thought we
were like losing our minds in 2006 we
moved from analog to digital finally put
in all new equipment all digital
everything and that's the year that Matt
Aaron who's our chief engineer joined us
now Matt is a genius he's one of these
people that can build something from
nothing when it comes to running wires
when it comes to keeping things running
and update it keeps the show running
24/7 and he can take apart microphones
computers he doesn't just have to buy
stuff and plug it together he can take
it all apart put it back together and
cause it to work and does frequently
because we're pretty scrappy around here
and so he keeps everything running and
updated and this show is never has never
had technical problems that were
insurmountable or huge or ongoing or
systemic or systemic or whatever while
Matt has been here since 2006 the show
works because of that and so if you
didn't know the way our show works the
way you get to listen to it if you're
listening on terrestrial radio is the
show leaves here on a dedicated digital
fiber optic line goes to New York City
to ABC who we buy our digital satellite
time from they shoot it up to the
satellite we call that the bird the
shoes shooted up to the bird and then
the radio stations take it off the bird
meaning they receive from
space the signal with their large dishes
and they run it through their broadcast
facility out over their antenna and into
your car and all of that happens in less
than a second and a half it's pretty
amazing technology if you think about it
and that's how 588 radio stations are
hearing me talk right now
that's pretty cool and of course we can
do TV spots the same way we redid the
studio in 2013 for a video channel which
has become a big deal
of course the podcast has launched out
and has become absolutely huge
technology as our friend now man it we
you know we used to have to ship
commercials across the country by tape
now we send them by you know email it's
ridiculous wonderful it's come a long
way baby I'll tell you that this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]